Columbia Columbia food there is no
mistaking that this is from Columbia or
any two colors in the Columbia but oh it
is there it is Oh didn't see that one
coming oh dude this smells like piranha
the Brazilian tree no it does not yeah
no it doesn't it kind of tastes like a
melted shaped ice I love it it's really
good
just pull oh yeah Wow
like a plantain pancake of us it's like
they were like let's take all the best
parts of a plantain and just like let's
take the sweet part and get rid of it
this substantial if you go to a club and
you're drinking you have a couple of
these you'll be fine love plantains when
they're fried once I love any more of
their fried twist
I kind of think it looks like a pokeball
that was discovered by Indiana Jones
ancient stone okay cool it looks like
the thing from spice but also no one
seems surprised you see that's why I
never seen I've never seen spice mm-hmm
on the spectrum between like sweet and
cheese like smack dab in the middle
god dammit Colombier just so good this
is good cuz it's its food and also
doubles as a frisbee this chorizo smells
incredible Wow yep Wow there's so much
density of spice in that chorizo you
don't need this bread she's extra carbs
y'all yeah we don't need those carbs
there's a cow farm this is what they
used to say moon this isn't just strips
of time this is an entire tongue entired
tongue all right that's really good
Cooper thought that is buttery a stone
the giant Nutter Butter
it's a Columbian Oreo I know how it's
gonna break so I want to punch it
whoa nice clean break yeah it's really
good fun to eat hard to punch it's just
so sad what's happening over there oh
yeah you don't know the half of it